on the subject of white supremacy that's
a subject every day of course
uh even though they're about they're
about 12 white supremacists
in the country but um this is what we
have to worry about is white supremacy
is the major problem
so aoc had some thoughts about the surge
at the border um
which we're not supposed to call it that
but she had some thoughts on it which
she shared on
on instagram and here it is they want to
say
what about the surge well
first of all just gut check
stop anyone who's using the term surge
around you consciously is trying to
invoke a militaristic frame
and that's a problem because
these this is not a surge these are
children and they are not insurgents
and we are not being invaded which by
the way
is a white supremacist
idea philosophy the idea that
if an other is coming in the population
that this is like an invasion of who we
are
yeah white supremacists right because
white people invented that
that people who are on the outside of
your group your tribe
are in other and when they come they're
invading
that's a white supremacist idea
is that is that what we hear for the
native american groups all the time
do we always hear about the european
invasion of the americas
so that's white supremacist white
supremacist to say that about white
well but of people not in that case it's
not because we know that the term whites
are
you i i i still hear somehow
um normal sane rational people even
conservatives using the term white
supremacy
you know as if it still means something
you got to just stop using that word
you know because you're you're you're
accepting the left's framework
the word now it doesn't mean anything
anymore it just doesn't you can't use it
it has no meaning white supremacy now is
whatever they don't like is white
supremacy
that's that's all it means they have
they have
stripped it of of any other meaning
by the way serge she says it's your uh
your consciously
if you use the word surge consciously
as opposed to what using it
unconsciously
but if you use it consciously then
you're it's a militaristic white
supremacist framework she says
well the the definition according to the
dictionary definition of surge is a
sudden powerful forward or upward
movement especially by a crowd or by a
natural force
such as the waves are tied
uh a crowd or a natural force moving
suddenly and powerfully forward or
upward okay so it's when uh when you got
a crowd of people
who are suddenly moving in a certain
direction
that's what surge means
you've got a crowd of people moving in a
certain direction so like let's say for
example
a crowd of illegal immigrants moving
up north
it's almost like what would you call
that a surge i don't know
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated